what's happening right now on mainstream
media is they're finally starting to
catch on that something might be brewing
with this Biden scandal okay the Biden
scandal is all over the place because
not only is it about these classified
documents but also that at as he was
vice president that Hunter was getting
jobs with the ukrainians that he didn't
uh wasn't qualified for and that Biden
might have been compromised himself so
here's a little bit uh from CNN from CNN
believe it or not on that a CNN review
of the laptop data as well as other
public material shows that Joe Biden did
interact with some of his son's
Associates while serving as vice
president though it's unclear exactly
what was discussed one example the
Republican site Miguel Aleman magnani a
Mexican businessman and Son of the
former president who Hunter was trying
to woo in 2014 Aleman magnani and his
dad were photographed at the White House
with then Vice President Biden in a
later email Hunter Biden reminds alimony
magnani of the favors he's done for him
we have been talking about business
deals and Partnerships for seven years I
have brought every single person you
have ever asked me to bring to the
effing White House and the vice
president's house and the inauguration
Hunter Biden bluntly acknowledged the
power of the Biden name in a memoir
writing that the Ukrainian Energy
company barisma which put him on its
board considered my last name gold I
don't think that there's a lot of things
that would have happened my life that
that if my last name wasn't five
oh [ __ ] Sherlock uh because whoever was
selling you the crack probably wouldn't
have marked it up but they mark up crack
for a Biden if that's what I've heard
that's what I've heard on the street
um so you see something's happening here
something's happening here all of us
that have been talking about this level
of corruption and obviously something
involving his son and barisma and the
laptop
something's going on now where it's
reaching mainstream that may just be
because they feel that the machine just
feels we're done with Biden he got us he
beat Trump got us through the midterms
we got to get rid of this guy now he
served his purpose and he is the
ultimate type of swamp creature right he
has been in public office for I think 48
years at this point and now they're
ready to put him out to pastor but it's
not just his relationship with Hunter
Biden that's the problem here even his
own brother his Joe Biden's brother's
business dealings are related to Joe and
the family name and all that stuff
Joe Biden's Brothers have repeatedly
referenced him in their private dealings
Frank Biden a developer of for-profit
charter schools has invoked his brother
in trying to convince local officials to
approve his projects like in Sunrise
Florida where he told the city in 2015
to trust his Venture not because of
Frank
but because of the honor of being the
brother of a guy I think we all know and
love in 2021 at a gathering of medical
professionals he made this pledge
have as a result of the privilege of
being associated with with my brother
Joey and I'll do everything in my power
to support you to get the job done to
get federal dollars to
to search
oh the president's brother was going to
do everything he could to get federal
dollars for people that were connected
to him through business does that sound
like it might be some sort of shady
thing do you think if that certain
orange Man's brother had done that sort
of thing that people might be looking
into that
foreign
[Music]